Leonardo padura Muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
France 24 Gracias a ustedes por la
invitación Gracias en tu última novela
personas decentes es de nuevo tu famoso
héroe Mario Conde que nos guía por las
calles de La Habana por los olores los
colores las texturas los recuerdos de
esta ciudad que desde siempre Parece ser
el segundo personaje central de tus
libros Tú ves la Habana como un
personaje con emociones pensamientos que
puede envejecer Mira esta es una novela
que desde el principio dije es la más
policiaca y la más habanera que he
escrito es la más policíaca porque
Generalmente en mis novelas y los
lectores que me conocen lo saben a mí
con un muerto me alcanza para escribir
una novela en esta en principio hay
cuatro dos cadáveres en una historia que
ocurre en el presente dos en una
historia que ocurre en el pasado en 1909
1910 y
esto ocurre en la Habana yo digo que
esta novela que tiene estas dos
historias que corren en paralelo
las líneas paralelas como todos sabemos
se unen en el infinito y el infinito de
esta de esta novela es Mario Conde y la
Habana Mario Conde porque Mario Conde es
quien escribe la historia del pasado y
protagoniza La del presente y porque la
Habana es un escenario muy importante
esa Habana de principios del siglo 20
inicios de la República después de la
guerra de Independencia
que entra en el mundo de la modernidad
de una manera esto avasallante llega el
ejército de intervención norteamericano
y necesita cambiar la infraestructura de
la ciudad modernizarla y es la época en
que llegan los tranvías el teléfono se
hacen carreteras edificios y
también es una época en la que hay por
ejemplo una enorme influencia francesa
en la en la vida en la vida cubana y
toda una un refinamiento Porque si bien
la modernidad viene de los Estados
Unidos El refinamiento de esa modernidad
viene de Europa y viene sobre todo de
Francia en eso en esos momentos y se
construye esa Habana que la vemos
después en el año 2016 en una época de
una cierta decadencia pero viviendo un
momento de efervescencia alrededor de un
acontecimiento histórico muy importante
que fue la visita del presidente
Obama a Cuba y y todo el el espacio
geográfico de la ciudad es también un
espacio cultural y sobre todo un espacio
espiritual que para mí es muy importante
para mí es muy importante a mí me
preguntan a veces Bueno tú eres un
escritor cubano yo digo si soy un
escritor cubano Pero eso es mentira yo
soy realmente un escritor habanero y
también eso es mentira soy un escritor
de mantilla un barrio de La Habana
porque
toda mi apropiación de la realidad parte
de ese de ese conocimiento e incluso
ahora estoy hablando contigo en en mi en
mi lenguaje neutro y para periodistas y
para entrevista pero yo hablo un
habanero
que se lo llevo a mis personajes porque
es una de las formas de entender y de
vivir la vida en la ciudad incluso a
nivel de las palabras de la comunicación
Y qué tal el futuro Cómo imaginas la van
En 20 30 50 años Mira hacen predicciones
de futuro es de los ejercicios más
complicados que uno que uno se pueda se
pueda imaginar y
y te voy a poner dos dos ejemplos que
tienen que ver con con mi trabajo
en en octubre de 1989 yo visité por
primera vez la casa de Trotsky en México
en Coyoacán México
y quince días después cayó el muro de
Berlín mientras yo estaba en la casa de
Trotsky Yo creo que ni yo ni nadie
imaginó que 15 días después el mundo iba
a dar esa voltereta histórica que dio en
esta novela se habla de ese momento en
que Obama llega a Cuba y hay toda una
serie de esperanzas de cambio esto el
primero de noviembre de ese año 2016 yo
creo que nadie apostaba que porque
Donald Trump fuera el próximo presidente
de los Estados Unidos y tres días
después ganó las elecciones eso y cambió
toda esta historia que que estaba
ocurriendo en Cuba porque revirtió todas
las políticas de la línea que revirtió
las políticas de Obama general y en con
Cuba muy en particular Entonces
yo más que hacer predicciones lo que me
gusta me lo que trato de expresar este
dos Yo quisiera que la Habana es un
futuro La Habana tiene que cambiar la
Habana tiene una infraestructura en
estos momentos completamente
deformada
antigua no funcional y tiene que cambiar
para vivir como la ciudad moderna que
necesitará ser en cualquier momento en
algún momento y ojalá que esa
intervención
la podamos hacer con la experiencia por
ejemplo de lo que ha ocurrido en
determinadas ciudades latinoamericanas
que ha sido más una invasión que una
evolución una invasión de lo moderno que
una evolución Entonces cómo Cómo
congeniar salvar el espíritu de una
ciudad
con toda esa estructura
ecléctica que que tiene la Habana con
con un modernismo que a veces es muy
agresivo y muy de aluminio y Cristal
Bueno hay que ver cómo ocurre pero lo
más importante de esto y y siempre
insisto es que
las ciudades son un espacio para que
vivan las personas
Cómo van a vivir esas personas porque el
que está viviendo hoy en un edificio
miserable de La Habana lo que quiere es
que tumben ese edificio y hagan el
edificio que sea pero que sea mejor esto
no le importa si es de hierro y cristal
o de lo que sea porque está mal viviendo
y merece vivir mejor entonces hay que
hay que buscar los equilibrios posibles
y Ojalá aparezca el equilibrista que
permita tener una mejor Habana en el
futuro y bueno para volver a Mario Conde
hablas de este personaje como de un
policía que hubiera querido ser escritor
es esta frustración estos sueños
escondidos lo que hacen los buenos
personajes
los buenos personajes tienen que ver con
el demonio
yo creo
yo creo que si un personaje si un
personaje no tiene Demonio No no es
bueno y Y dónde tiene en realidad poco
demonio y tal vez lo que ha logrado que
que tenga una una cercanía con con la
gente es es ese carácter un poco
pesimista
nostálgico melancólico
la sus fidelidades su fidelidad a los
amigos a la literatura a la verdad y y
yo siempre digo que Conde no es un
escritor frustrado es un escritor
pospuesto y cada vez más Conde va siendo
un escritor activo en la novela anterior
la transparencia del tiempo escribe toda
una serie de pasajes que ocurren en la
historia y aquí ocurre escribe casi la
mitad de la novela está escrita por
Conde es decir que cada vez más Conde
participa en la en la creación y y yo
siempre digo que cuando deci terminar
con el personaje de conde quisiera
escribir una novela en la que Conde
fuera el escritor y yo servirle de
vehículo entre su escritura y la
publicación
porque porque creo que tendría cosas que
decir No sé si será una novela de
carácter policial
existencial esto política no lo sé
todavía no tengo ese ese plan definido
pero me gustaría me gustaría mucho sería
de una cierta manera cerrar el ciclo la
cerrar el ciclo con Conde que ha sido un
personaje literario que se ha ido
convirtiendo Mira me pasa con con cierta
frecuencia en Cuba y fuera de Cuba que
la gente me pregunta por Mario Conde me
dice Oye y qué es de la vida del
personaje de Mario Conde cuándo vuelve
Mario Conde y Conde y Tamara la la su
compañera me preguntan a veces hasta por
el perro de Mario Conde Y eso es muy
bonito porque el personaje ha dejado
personaje literario para convertirse en
una persona y y esa persona tengo que
darle también la posibilidad de
expresión y de manera más general sobre
esta serie con Mario Conde que te
permite la novela policíaca que no te
permiten los otros géneros que te gusta
de este género específico Mira ya a
estas alturas de la evolución de la
literatura
considerar la novela negra o novela
policial o novela de investigación de
crímenes como como un género
independiente yo creo que no tiene
demasiado sentido
en el caso francés por ejemplo
las últimas novelas de de Manuel carrera
o las últimas de Michelle ulebec
son policiacas o no son policiacas son
filosóficas son históricas son sociales
son políticas Yo creo que
la gran ganancia que hemos tenido los
escritores en el en con la la llegada y
la
eclosión de el sentido posmoderno de la
creación es que
violamos las fronteras violamos la
fronteras y una novela de carácter
policial puede servir para hacer
reflexiones filosóficas
políticas sociales
literarias no hay no hay por qué pensar
que por escribir una novela policíaca
tienes que escribirla con un lenguaje
claro esto y transparente para que la
gente lea la historia de un Enigma sigue
ocurriendo sigue ocurriendo hay mucha
novela
sobre todo nórdica que han tenido un
gran éxito que son novelas escritas de
manera muy elemental muy elemental y
tienen gran éxito pero yo creo que
el escritor que Que decida utilizar
determinados recursos de la de la novela
policial en función de la expresión de
la problemática que quiera del carácter
que quiera está en condiciones de
hacerlo porque es un género muy abierto
es un sistema que dejó de tener esa
característica de aquí hay un Enigma que
yo tengo que develar tengo que encontrar
sino que son más bien propuestas de
búsqueda de una verdad y y en esa
búsqueda de la verdad y bueno la novela
policíaca perfectamente sirve para
cualquier fin estético
ideológico social el que uno quiera
utilizar bueno Muchas gracias Leonardo
tadura gracias a ustedes
[Música]